this video is kindly sponsored by
curiositystream
find out more a little later in the
video hey
42 here on the 1st of april 2002
a 96 year old man passed away quietly
in an old people's home on the south
coast of finland
he looked small in death he'd stood only
five feet tall in his prime
and old age had chunking him further
still
many years before he'd been a farmer
who'd kept himself
to himself he'd never married
and had no children but the few people
who got close enough to think of him as
a friend
called him simo in his youth however
many decades earlier
he'd been known by another name
one usually whispered by nervous looking
men in snow-covered forests
who scanned the horizon constantly and
jumped at every sound
these men had never met simo and
therefore didn't know his real name
so they gave him another one
the white death that might seem like a
grand title for a diminutive finnish
farmer but it was a very fitting one
because over the space of 98 days in
in the quiet snow-drenched landscape of
his native country
semo became death incarnate
a perfect killing machine that snuffed
out the lives of men
by the hundreds this is the story
of simo hyeha known to his enemies
as the white death the greatest
sniper who ever lived
this story about the greatest sniper who
ever lived is incredibly
interesting and if you love stuff like
this like i do
then i know you'll enjoy curiosity
stream curiosity stream is
the netflix for nerds the hulu for
history buffs
the disney plus for the scientist in us
it offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals the best
thing about curiosity stream
is that it's available worldwide they
are continuously updating their content
and adding new and exciting titles
spanning science history nature
technology
society and lifestyle as you probably
know
i adore history and i'm absolutely
loving their enormous
high quality history selection one of my
favorites
is how to build a castle which follows a
team of medieval enthusiasts in france
who are building an actual castle in the
modern day using
only historically accurate building
techniques
i genuinely loved every minute of that
one
so if you're anything like me and you
love to learn new things
then you should check it out you can
have unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries
and non-fiction series starting at only
2.99 a month
or just 19.99 for the whole year
and if you head to curiositystream.com
forward slash 42 and use my promo code
42 then the first 30 days
will be completely free simo was born in
a tiny hamlet in south west finland
in 1905. he had a pretty normal
childhood for the time
volunteering in the civil guard at the
age of 17
and completing his mandatory national
service at 19
where he became a member of the bicycle
battalion
a unit of cycle riding light infantry
if the idea of soldiers on push bikes
sounds a little comical
you might be surprised to learn that at
the time bicycles were considered
genuine vehicles of war
they played a significant part in the
first world war
and were still being used in the second
albeit in smaller numbers
despite this early brush with the
military semo had no martial ambitions
and every intention of spending his life
at home on his farm
so after completing his mandatory
service
that's exactly where he went but
over the years the atmosphere across
europe began to darken
and by the late 1930s simo would be
called to serve his country
in one of its most desperate hours it
started in 1939 as the world teated on
the brink of all-out war
when germany and the soviet union signed
a non-aggression agreement
that became known as the molotov
ribbon-trop pact
the deal stunned the world not only had
the soviets been negotiating
unsuccessfully with the french and
british for months at the time
but the germans and soviets were
long-time adversaries who
pretty much hated each other's guts but
as shocking as the pact between
the two old rivals was there was even
more to the deal than met the eye
because behind closed doors a secret
protocol had been
slipped into the agreement in which
hitler and stalin
had essentially divided the countries of
europe up between them
based on what they called their spheres
of influence
just over a week later germany and the
dictators
jointly invaded poland the germans from
the west
and then 16 days later the soviets did
the same
from the east claiming half of the
conquered country each
by the way the molotov of the molotov
ribbon-trop
pact is the very same man for whom the
now
well-known cocktail you definitely don't
want to drink
was named after during the brief war
that was fought between
finland and the soviet union after the
signing of the molotov-ribbentrop pact
the same war that would soon make a
living legend at a semo high
the soviets conducted widespread bombing
of finnish cities
but dropping bombs on your neighbors is
generally frowned upon by the
international community
and so via cheslav molotov soviet
minister of foreign affairs
conducted a propaganda campaign
insisting his nation
wasn't bombing the finns but was instead
delivering food packages like the good
friendly neighbour it was
the finns demonstrating an admiral sense
of humor
considering they were getting shell to
at the time
started jokingly referring to these
bombs as
molotov bread baskets when soviet tanks
began
trundling over the border shortly
afterwards the finns responded by
pelting them with improvised
bottle-based incendiary devices
which they called molotov cocktails
a drink to go with the food parcels via
cheslav molotov
had so kindly forced to send them
anyway after the german soviet invasion
of poland
the soviets began doling out ultimatums
to the other countries deemed to be in
their
sphere of influence including lithuania
latvia estonia and finland
the baltic states were soon forced to
accept stalin's demands
but the finns stood firm turning down
his
kind offer of handing over a bunch of
their land
in exchange for not being murdered their
bullying diplomatic approach having
failed the soviets decided to let their
soldiers do the talking
commencing a full-scale invasion of
finland
in november of 1939
the winter war had begun
finland is a land of lakes swamps and
densely packed forests and when stalin's
army attacked
most of that was buried beneath a thick
layer of snow
the challenging conditions made it
difficult for the soviets to
successfully deploy
the full might of their forces and
the finns who were far better prepared
began to engage in their own
unique brand of guerrilla warfare
even so finland had a population of just
3.7 million at the time
meaning there were close to 50 soviets
for
every single fin when the red army
crossed the border at several strategic
points they brought with them thousands
of
tanks and aircraft the finnish army
on the other hand had just 32 tanks to
its name
along with around 100 aircraft and an
unknown number of bicycles armed with
really loud bells and those clicky
things you put on the spokes
in short the finns needed a hero
and a short hero is exactly what they
got
this was very much a david and goliath
clash but when goliath turned up to this
particular fight
david was nowhere to be seen you see
he'd hidden himself in a snow bank
more than a kilometer away and he was
packing a sniper rifle
simo's national service had ended a good
years before he was called up to fight
in the winter war
but that didn't mean he was rusty in
many ways
he'd been in unintentional training ever
since he'd left the army
stalking forests he knew like the back
of his hand
in search of elusive game his trusty
rifle
slung over one shoulder and making the
transition from
master hunter to god level sniper
turned out to be fairly simple
conditions during the winter war were
brutal
with temperatures generally fluctuating
between -20
and -40 degrees celsius but
simo didn't mind in fact he didn't even
think of the conditions as particularly
harsh
to him it was just winter and so he put
on some more clothes
and got on with it the red army on the
other hand
was woefully ill-prepared the men were
given standard-issue uniforms in a kind
of
dark khaki colour meaning they stood out
like shining beacons as they patrolled
the endless white
of the finnish wilderness simo and his
fellow snipers
on the other hand were decked out in
pure white
camo gear making them next to invisible
within days at the start of the war it
became clear
seemer was no ordinary marksman
it wasn't just that he could make shots
that were practically
impossible to the other men it was also
his machine-like
consistency once the target entered his
crosshairs
no matter the difficulty of the shot
simo
almost never missed and yes it wasn't
just his outrageous skill
that set him apart for starters simo
didn't use the same
state-of-the-art sniper rifle with
telescopic sights
that his fellow soldiers favored instead
using the same old
basic rifle he'd been issued years
before
during his days in the civil guard a far
simpler weapon equipped only with iron
sights
that's right as crazy as it sounds
the deadliest sniper in the history of
mankind
didn't even use a scope and you don't
need to play call of duty to know that
no scopes
are hard the stuff of youtube
compilation legends
but that's just how semo preferred to do
things
and in fact forgoing the scope had a
couple of important benefits that
extended his edge on the battlefield
a sniper using a telescopic sight has to
raise his head a few centimeters
in order to look through the scope
presenting a marginally larger target
to the enemy semo also realized that
telltale flashes of sunlight from enemy
scopes
were often what gave them away something
he knew
better than most could be fatal as well
as his unusual choice of weapon
simo was meticulous in his preparations
for battle
he would visit his favorite firing
positions in the middle of the night
checking they hadn't been discovered by
the enemy
and ready them for action the following
day
shaping the snow to better conceal his
position
and flattening any powder to ensure it
didn't puff up when he fired
giving him away simo left absolutely
nothing to chance
making the most out of every advantage
available to him
to augment that uncanny marksmanship of
his
he even went so far as to keep snow in
his mouth
while sniping cooling his breath
so it wouldn't be visible after
condensing in the frigid air
had seemo merely been a good shot
he would have most likely come out of
the winter war with scores of confirmed
kills to his name
but by combining that remarkable skill
level
with all of these different tactics he
became
a force of nature
the war between finland and the soviet
union was brief
lasting just over 100 days and yet
during that time the man who would
become known as
the white death amassed over
500 enemy kills at an average
of more than five per day the exact
number of confirmed kills
is unknown but most sources put simo's
tally
at between 505 and 542
kills the most of any sniper
in history to put those numbers into
perspective
arguably the most famous sniper of
recent years
chris kyle subject of the film american
sniper
had 160 confirmed kills to his name
gained across four tours of duty during
the iraq war
and 10 years of service another
legendary sniper
hero of the soviet union vasily zaitsev
who became known to western audiences
after being played by jude law
in enemy at the gates is credited with
242 kills
during 80 years of service in the second
world war
simo's kill count dwarfs both of these
and he achieves defeat in a matter of
months
not in the better part of a decade and
all this despite
using relatively basic gear and not even
being a career soldier
unsurprisingly rumors of an almost
supernatural sniper
who never missed began to spread amongst
the red army soldiers
and the legend of the white death
began to grow the soviets became so
concerned about the number of men they
were losing
to this mysterious finnish ghost
they sent literally scores of their own
snipers to hunt him down
but simo dispatched each and
every one of them becoming more
desperate
they tried to bomb simo out with mortar
fire
but he picked his hiding spots carefully
sniping from natural foxholes and deep
snow banks
nothing less than a direct hit would
have taken him out
and since the soviets were never quite
sure exactly where he was
even as he picked them off one by one
they never managed it that is until the
final week of the war
when an explosive round caught him in
the face during a particularly fierce
battle
simo's fellow soldiers later found his
body unmoving
in the snow and grieving for their
fallen hero
solemnly placed him with the dead but
hours after the battle had ended a
soldier noticed movement amongst the
piled bodies
a twitching leg remarkably
despite having lost his upper jaw most
of his lower jaw
and the whole of his left cheek seemo
was alive he was taken to the hospital
immediately where he would remain in a
coma for a full week before regaining
consciousness
on the day peace was declared with the
soviet union
his injuries were terrible and he would
require 26 surgeries
over the following years to mends the
damage to his face
though he remained badly scarred for the
rest of his life
the winter war ended with the moscow
peace treaty
in which finland ceded border territory
to the soviets
in exchange for the cessation of
hostilities
whilst the finns ended up losing more
lands than the soviets had demanded
before the war
most observers believe stalden had meant
to seize the entire country by force
something which he was ultimately unable
to do so
thanks to the bravery of men like sema
in the face of overwhelming gods
by the end of the war simo had become a
genuine national hero
and he was promoted from the rank of
corporal to second lieutenant
as a reward for his service it remains
to this day
the single biggest promotion ever given
to a soldier in the finnish army
he was also given a farm it was called
white lake a fitting home for the man
called
the white death despite the truly
terrifying number of kills to his name
semo never reveled in his work
in his diaries discovered for the first
time in 2017
he referred to the staggering number of
men he'd killed as his
sin list he rarely talked about the war
but not long before his death he was
asked if he regretted having taken the
lives of so many men
his response was typically modest
i did what i was told to do as well as i
could
there would be no finland unless
everyone else
had done the same thanks for watching